Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
Đỗ Bảo Nam Vlog video ngày hôm nay Đỗ
Bảo Nam blog chia sẻ với bạn cách xóa
khoảng trắng trong Word
cho ví dụ trong phái buốt này bạn nhìn
thấy có rất nhiều khoảng trắng thường
bây giờ để xóa khoảng trắng này các bạn
thực hiện theo 2 bước sau
Khi bữa thứ nhất bạn nhấn tổ hợp phím
Control + h để mở hộp thoại Tìm kiếm và
thay thế
anh ở đây mình sẽ nhấn tổ hợp phím
Control + h
ạ sau đó Bước thứ hai
Anh ở trong cái phần file which bạn Nhập
khai khoảng trắng thức là hai dấu cách
A và trong phần zipp reach bạn Nhập một
khoảng trắng
sau đó bạn Click vào ziprasidone
như vậy bạn nhìn thấy có 19 khoảng trắng
đã được thay thế
A và mình sẽ đóng cái cửa sổ này
trong trường hợp bạn vẫn còn khoảng
trắng thì bạn thực hiện lại cái thao tác
này bằng cách nhấn cầu phím Control h
Vì sao đó bạn vẫn nhập hay khoảng trắng
vào ô file Word
và một khoảng trắng và walrus which đ
ạ sau đó bạn click Flip Zidane
ở đây bạn nhìn thấy có một kết quả Nếu
như trong trường hợp khái quát của bạn
vẫn còn thì bạn tiếp tục thay thế
và đến trường hợp không còn kết quả nào
nữa thì như vậy tất cả các khoảng trắng
đã được xóa bỏ bây giờ mình cắt và ok và
đóng cửa sổ
Thế bạn thấy trong file này tất cả các
khoảng nhân thừa đã được xóa bỏ
phải như vậy Ở nội dung video vừa rồi
đâu Bảo Nam vào lúc vừa chia sẻ nhanh
với bạn cách xóa khoảng trắng trong Word
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn anh nhất Chuyển còn ai và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam với Đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video cũng từ đỗ Em xin cảm ơn các
bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam Vlog
và truy cập website đô bảo now.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blog để xem
thêm các video cũng như thủ thuật máy
tính tay Producer
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bà Nam vào lúc chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết hôi mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo